So JP, I did initial competitor analysis
and I estimated what the user base is
out there, and kind of what
the cash opportunity is, and
I gotta say things
are looking pretty good.
Now there are a couple of other
competitors in this space.
But if we focus on things like the
realtime update nature of the app and
the collaborative nature of the app,
I think we really have the runway
to make this idea take off.
>> Great, so you mentioned some
initial wireframes for the app?
>> Yeah.
I think we'll want to
divide this into stages.
We can call these versions and
release the app to testers accordingly.
Version 0.1 is where we'll decide what
kind of stack we're going to use.
Once we've done that,
we'll take the minimum viable product,
also known as the simplest
version of the app.
That version will be
focused on writing and
reading one piece of data from the
online data store that we just set up.
>> Sounds good, and then in version 0.2
you could build out the other screens,
create the bulk of the data that
gets stored in the database, and
decide how to visualize it and
connect it to the database.
>> We're going to need to add user
authentication at some point.
>> That could be for version 0.3.
You could add a sign in and create
account screen to the app that will
allow for authentication and
user accounts.
>> That sounds good.
And in the 0.4 release, we can cover how
to use all the user data that we just
grabbed to allow for sharing user lists.
Also, since we're
accumulating all that data,
we'll probably want some way to sort and
filter it.
And you'll need to adjust security and
permissions at some point.
You don't want to have your data just
laying around for anyone to access.
Maybe that's shopping list plus
plus 0.5 or maybe that's 1.0.
>> Okay, so it looks like we have a
pretty good road map of the app sketched
out, but I'll keep checking in with you
both to make sure that we're on track.